president biden finally holds a press
conference and looks absolutely awful
biden's obvious decline doesn't stop the
left from pushing ever more radical cram
downs and
another hunter biden scandal breaks i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from bigtech with vpn
i trust visit expressvpn.com
slash ben will get to all the news in
just one moment first the word is out
people are abandoning
their overpriced wireless carriers they
are flocking to pure talk for the same
exact coverage but at a fraction of the
price
that is correct if you're with verizon
or att or t-mobile if you switch to pure
talk
you could take your family over 800 a
year and switching is really simple you
can keep your phone keep your number or
get huge discounts on the latest iphones
and androids for example i got that
iphone 12. i love it i'm getting the
same great coverage
for half the price right now you can get
unlimited talk tech six gigs of data for
just 30 bucks a month so here's the
thing
the other wireless companies they're
going to charge you for unlimited data
you don't need unlimited data you're not
using unlimited data
all you really need is a limited talk
and unlimited text and six
gigs of data for 30 bucks a month and
here's the thing if you go over on the
data you're worried about that well
they're not going to charge you for it
so what exactly do you have to lose
there is a reason pure talk is the
highest rated wireless company by
consumer affairs stop giving your money
to overpriced wireless carriers and
start
saving money today from your cell phone
dial pound 250
say ben shapiro you'll save 50 off your
very first month that is pound two five
zero
say my name ben shapiro pure talk is
simply smarter wireless just dial pound
250 say ben shapiro you'll save 50
off your very first month at pure talk
usa okay so
yesterday joe biden finally held his
long awaited press conference this is
the longest that a president has waited
to give
an actual press conference in a century
and there's a reason because he is not
with us
he is not okay so the last several
nights my baby has woken me up in the
middle of the night and she's kept me up
for hours at a time
and you start to feel when you're
deprived of sleep that you're beginning
to lack a brain function well joe biden
does not lack for sleep joe biden is
just in decline
and you know i i honest to god i
hesitate to make fun of the guy
because it's really kind of tragic it
really is sad i mean he is the president
of the united states
he is the guy who is in charge and he is
clearly not in charge he is clearly not
with us the media are doing whatever
they can
to cover over this fact it's amazing you
know for many many years in this country
whenever there would be a problem with
the president the press
trying to do its best to cover for that
president would just cover it up so
woodrow wilson was basically a vegetable
for the last couple of years of his
administration and edith was actually
running the country
and the press fearful of the american
public knowing this just refused to
report it
fdr was clearly in decline in the last
years of his presidency and the press
deeply afraid
to cover that accurately just didn't
cover it jfk
was a scuzz bag with women the press in
his pocket just didn't cover it it was
something that they just left under the
table it's been a while in america
since presidents got the kind of
treatment that that joe biden is getting
right now
barack obama got kid glove treatment
from the press but he wasn't obviously
in decline there was not this massive
gap between what he was publicly
and what he was behind close and how the
media were covering him with joe biden
what is perfectly obvious to you in
front of your eyes as being overtly
denied
by a media that is declaring that joe
biden is not only with us he is in
control
he is just he is cool as a cucumber and
here is a piece from the washington post
describing joe biden's press conference
yesterday and then we're going to
contrast
our establishment media who are just
playing human centipede with joe biden
at this point they are at the back of
that human centipede
contrast that with what you actually saw
with your own eyes which was a president
who is obviously in a state of cognitive
decline
a president who again i i say this with
with no sense
of of excitement or joy or happiness in
any way it is very sad to watch
to watch again the elected president of
the most powerful country in the history
of humanity
not be with us and then to
simultaneously be told that he is with
us so he can push forward a radical
agenda and that's what this is
because yesterday was a combination of
incoherence and radic and radicalism
that's what the the combo was the
combination was a man who can't get
through a sentence without a binder
of notes in front of him and an agenda
that would make lbj blush
it's incredible and the media are
papering over that because they like the
agenda the media are just they're not
even his stenographers the media are
indistinguishable
from the press wing of the democratic
party there shouldn't even be a white
house press room they should just
actually absorb the press
into the white house because at this
point the establishment press our
propaganda outlet for the president of
the united states so long as he is of
the correct party
it's it's an amazing thing to watch
here's the headline from the washington
post today
after this press conference president's
policy approach is quote the art of the
possible
i mean to make the man sound as though
he is a transformational leader
who is who is aspirational and somebody
who's going to bring us forward to a
brighter future as opposed to a man who
is managing his own decline as well as
the decline of the nation in pretty poor
fashion
the washington post says president joe
biden answering the 29th question
in his first presidential news
conference on the 65th day in office
offered one of the clearest
distillations of his theory
of his presidency and how its success
will be measured it's clear
his distillation and my god what an
incredible guy he answered 29 questions
29 what an amazing except the questions
were all like
so joe how wonderful are you and how bad
was trump
and can you explain just how
transformational you're going to be
so according to the washington post he
said quote it's a matter of timing
he said in an answer in which he was
referring to gun control measures but
could have been referencing almost any
part of his agenda
as you've all observed successful
presidents better than me have been
successful in part large in large part
because they knew
how to time what they're doing order it
decide it and prioritize what needs to
be done
the arc of history in biden's view comes
down to pragmatism this thing is just a
press release
it's a press release written by gen zaki
but it's not it's in the washington post
quote
it explains how he has approached his
opening months in office and how he is
looking at the coming years
it illustrates how he can describe some
republican policies as sick and
un-american
while not doing everything in his power
to immediately stop them he called the
filibuster a racist relic of jim crow
while also insisting he wasn't ready to
remove it entirely in the hopes there
would be some compromise
successful electoral politics is the art
of the possibility he's like lincoln
i mean this guy is just he's bringing
together the best people he is taking it
one step at a time his incrementalism
will be more transformational
than the aspirational words of his far
left compatriots
what an amazing guy okay so that's the
story that you're getting from the media
today the actual story of the press
conference is that joe biden
is not with us he was repeatedly
confused he wandered off in the middle
of sentences he never came back he did
it at least three separate times
during the press conference here's a
little bit of joe biden just wandering
off into the into the cornfield and we
have no idea where old joe went
am i giving you too long an answer
because if you don't want the detail
no no but i mean i i don't know how much
detail you want about immigration
maybe i'll stop there infinity so the
best way to get something done
if you if it holds near and dear to you
that you uh
like to be able to anyway
i'm we're going to get a lot done but
folks
i'm going thank you very very much i
appreciate it thank you
okay that second that second statement
there
is just that is not somebody who's with
us
we can pretend we can we can all pretend
everything is fine
i'll just note that for four long years
every single thing that donald trump
said or did was used as an excuse
by the left and by the media as a as a
hook
to suggest that the 25th amendment
should be invoked
because he was not competent to fulfill
high office joe biden
wanders off in the middle of sentences
he doesn't know where he is or what he
is doing
and the media proclaimed him to be an
incredible president an incredible order
five minutes into this press conference
there were reporters who were tweeting
out about how
how in control he was by the end of the
press conference he had to be mopped off
the floor
and it wasn't as though he was asked to
have questions because he really was not
we'll get to more of this in just one
second again this gap is the real story
we know what biden is we know what
biden's going to do it's the gap between
reality and how the media are portraying
reality to the millions of americans who
didn't watch the press conference that
is truly
the tale of the the the tale worth
telling here we'll get to more of this
in a second first
here's the reality you text a lot i text
a lot
texting is really convenient i'll tell
you what if somebody calls me from a
business chances are very long to pick
up the phone and if somebody emails me
chances are very high that ends up in
the spam folder but if somebody texts me
pretty good shot that i'm going to
respond this is why if you are a
business
you need to make sure that you are in
the texting game if you've been around
long enough you remember that following
technology innovations in the 90s your
business needed an email address by the
2000s you needed a website by 2010
you needed to have a social media
presence and in 2021 you need to be
texting podium
is the messaging platform to power your
business it helps you reach your
customers wherever they are
business messaging with podium helps you
gain reviews collect payments
communicate with customers and capture
leads all
from a single inbox podium helps you
adapt to the changing of customer
expectations don't take my word for it
south tampa family and cosmetic
dentistry collected nearly 1200 reviews
averaging 4.9 stars via text dr wyatt of
south tampa family and cosmetic
dentistry said quote the number of
walk-ins as a result of our reviews has
skyrocketed
before we were seeing maybe 50 to 100
new patients a month now we are seeing
closer to 200. find out how podium can
help your business reach more customers
via text
it is the method your business needs to
be using get started free today
at podium.com shapiro that is podium.com
shapiro okay so more joe biden seeming
confused
falling apart and that one clip of him
falling apart is just the this is
this is the one here here is joe biden
again
any president who did this who was not a
democrat would immediately
immediately be expected to resign in
in fairly near order i mean if you watch
this press conference and the first
question that flashed your brain was not
how long can this guy last i'm not sure
what you were watching here was joe
biden yesterday
i'm going to say something outrageous i
have never been particularly poor at
calculating how to get things done
in the united states senate so the best
way to get something done
if you if it holds near and dear to you
that you
like to be able to anyway
i'm we're we're going to get a lot done
what what remember
he's completely in command he's in
control the drudge report which is
basically turned hard left now the
drudge reports headlines today are
joe's no drama press conference chill
style
grand vision for fdr presidency art of
the possible
those are the headlines over at drudge
report which as you'll recall used to be
a critic
of presidents who are of the left side
of the aisle now the drudge report is
apparently joining the stenography club
over at the over at the democratic
press establishment outlets by the way
joe biden couldn't get through this
press conference without notes okay he
was he was reading
from actual podium notes throughout the
press conference
he had a binder he was reading from a
briefing book
at the press conference because he
cannot be trusted to go out there and
simply riff on topics
not because like president trump he
makes wild statements or wild
generalizations but because
he literally is unable to speak with
coherence on a topic for more than five
minutes it's an amazing thing
amazing thing here was chris wallace
pointing this out hey chris wallace
again
no opponents of joe biden's chris weller
has been fairly warm toward joe biden
here's chris wallace from fox news
it seemed on every foreign policy
question not the others but on foreign
policy
he went to his briefing book like jen
saki does
sometimes in the briefings and was
reading obviously white house
guidance white house talking points uh
covering ronald reagan for six years i
never saw that
uh watching a lot of news conferences
over the years i've never seen that
a president and a news conference
reading talking points
remember ronald reagan was a dullard
actor who was in decline according to
the press and donald trump was a
patently insane person who was in
decline according to the press and joe
biden who's clearly in decline is
completely with it
he's sharp as a thumbtack according to
the new york post however
a newspaper that is not in the pocket of
the democratic party president biden
appeared to repeatedly lose his train of
thought early on in his first press
conference as commander-in-chief
thursday
asking reporters if they wanted him to
go into detail in his answers for
getting questions relying heavily on cue
cards
from a binder he brought along the
president took ten questions at the 62
minute presser repeatedly consulting his
binder before calling on the next report
by the way
when the washington post suggested he
took 29 questions they meant
that he took like little follow-ups from
the same reporters but overall he
filibustered a bunch of these questions
he'd be asked a question if he didn't
want to answer it he would just
ramble for several minutes on completely
unrelated topics
the first awkward moment occurred when
the president was answering a question
on the crisis at the southern border
from pbs journalist yamiche alcindor who
by the way again another press
stenographer for the president of the
united states
he he cut himself off in the middle of
the answer
he took alcindor's follow-up questions
in which she asked about the
deliberations for migrants being
permitted to stay as well as the
filibuster
and then he took her question on
migrants and needed to be reminded about
her filibuster he just forgot the second
question
now listen we have a robust system we
have a robust system that is capable of
carrying on even if the president of the
united states does not seem to be with
us but it is the gap between the reality
and how the media wish you to perceive
the reality that is
really worth talking about today i mean
biden was struggling to he had a list of
reporters he was going to call on
on that list was not fox news we'll get
to in a second imagine if president
trump
because he did this a couple of times
took press conferences and didn't once
call
on anyone from the left side of the
aisle he really didn't do that he called
on people from the left side of the
aisle just not cnn and the press were
like he's trying to avoid questions joe
biden would not call on anyone from fox
news which is really the only opposition
outlet in the room
okay but he did have a pre-screened list
of questioners
how transparent how refreshing and then
he got lost on his list he couldn't
remember who he was supposed to call on
here was joe biden yesterday okay
um hang on uh
sorry oh sing me miss kim
i mean this is incredible guys he
this is the leader of the free world and
also a man who just starts yelling for
no reason
he's talking about unions and all of a
sudden he's just like
turns in the swedish chef the hell is he
doing no one knows
so i'm running for three reasons to
restore the soul
dignity honor honesty transparency
to the american political system
two to rebuild the backbone of this
country
the middle class hard-working people and
people struggling
in the middle class they built america
and unions built them what are you why
are you yelling
why did somebody did somebody lose the
the
discount coupon to the early bird dinner
at denny's again why
why are you angry no why are you yelling
okay then we'll get to his actual policy
because here's the thing
the combination of the trojan horse that
is biden
i've suggested that he's a house plant
because he's hiding the water stain the
water stain is the radical policy
when you bring out a person who is
clearly feeble and then
you put him out there and it's
impossible to make jokes about a person
like this
honestly like it's very difficult to
make jokes about joe biden not because
in the democratic view he's just so
wonderful but because in reality making
jokes about people like biden in biden's
particular
position it seems mean and it seems
cruel because the man is clearly not
with us
and then they use the fact that he's not
with us in order to ram through a bunch
of untruths a bunch of lies a bunch of
radical policy positions
that extra that in extraordinary fashion
reshape the relationship between the
american people and their government
we'll get to that and the media just
cheer it they just cheer cause this is
what they want this is what they've
always wanted
they now have he's not just a trojan
horse for the radical left he's a trojan
horse for the media agenda because the
media
can craft him into whatever they want
him to be who are you going to trust
your lying eyes or the media we'll get
to that in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that you know
if you are a dude you start to lose your
hair typically in your mid-30s and
you value that hair okay you love your
hair you don't want to go full bruce
willis yet okay it's one thing to do it
when you're 60. it's another thing to do
it when you're in your 40s
nothing as uncomfortable and awkward as
losing that hair and that's why you need
four hymns it is your one stop shop for
hair loss and wellness for men
hymns is helping dudes be the best
version of themselves with licensed
medical providers and fda approved
products to help treat hair loss
no snake oil pills gas station counter
supplements prescription solutions
backed by science hymns was created by a
guy who knows that some
men's health conversations are easier
online than in person no more awkward
in-person doctor's visits or long
pharmacy lines
four hymns connects you to licensed
medical professionals online which could
save you hours it's completely
confidential it's completely discreet
answer a few quick questions a medical
professional will review if they
determine it's right for you
they can prescribe you medication to
treat hair loss that is shipped directly
to your door today hymns is giving you
their best offer yet
if you're not happy with your results
after 90 days hymns will give you a full
refund and right now
my listeners can get their first visit
absolutely free go to for hymns.com
ben that is for hims.com ben
prescription products require an online
consultation with a health card provider
will determine if a prescription is
appropriate restrictions applies to a
website for full details and important
safety information
remember that is for hims.com
ben go check them out right now okay so
then there is biden on policy
so here's the thing joe biden's feeble
health stanzing and when you watch him
again the first question that you're
asking is how is this guy going to make
it for four years
he actually said at his press conference
yesterday that he was going to run for
re-election
in 2024 and there's almost an audible
gasp in the room
here is joe biden saying that he was
going to run for re-election people are
like you're you're 78 now
and you don't seem like you're fully
with us you're going to run in four
years kamala harris somewhere in the
wings
just laughing cackling hysterically for
no reason here's joe biden
have you decided whether you are going
to run for re-election in 2024 you
haven't set up a re-election campaign
yet as your predecessor had by this time
my friend said i need to needed to
my predecessor oh god i miss him
have you have you oh and answer is yes
my plan is to run for re-election that's
my expectation
he made a trump joke so he can just
ignore the fact that uh the plausibility
of him running again
is very very low at this point but again
all of this is just a trojan horse for
the radicalism
it's a spoonful of senility to make the
medicine go down
that is what we are watching right now
okay and there are a few things that he
gets away with because of this one
the media just will not fact-check
untruth things he says they will
completely
repeat the nonsense where he establishes
a goal that has already been met so he
does this
all the time he'll say things when he
comes into office like well you know
i said 100 million shots in
100 days and nobody nobody thought
we could you know no one thought we
could
do this okay and they're already doing a
million shots today well now he's doing
the same thing now he's like you know
you know we're gonna we're gonna you
know push a stand we're gonna do more
shots than
well we're already doing that but you
know it's uh and peter like wow that's
amazing he's announced a new goal
they're already meeting here's joe biden
doing that yesterday
now today i'm setting the second goal
and that is
we will by my 100th day in office have
administered
200 million shots in people's arms
that's right 200 million shots in 100
days
i know it's ambitious twice our original
goal
but no other country in the world has
even come close
not even close to what we're doing
i believe we can do it okay first of all
our vaccine rollout has been very good
that's because of the states it's not
because joe biden
two when joe biden says we'll hit 200
million shots in a hundred days that's
because we're already doing that
we've been trenching out well over two
million shots today like right now that
is not a goal
and this is his entire administration
when it comes to pr
he jumps in front of a moving parade and
he's like this parade's for me
i i did it i made the i he gets up every
morning and he looks at the sky and he
goes
the sun is is gonna rise in the east
and set in in the west under my
administration and me
like amazing he just set a goal of the
sun rising in the east and setting in
the west clearly
this man is magic clearly he is
incredible
at his job okay so when he is not
setting goals that he has already met
to the cheers of a rabidly partisan
media he is also just saying absurd
radical insane things but it's okay
he's a nice old man don't point out that
he's a radical
stop that he's a moderate joe biden was
always now those of us during the
last campaign who pointed out that joe
biden was not a moderate that he was a
trojan horse for radicalism
the meteor like why why would you say
that about that nice old man he's a nice
old man
are you kidding he just eats oatmeal and
cream wheat he's fine
stop that well here's the thing he says
radical things
he he says more radical things than
barack obama did obama
sometimes tried to moderate his message
because he didn't want to appear radical
before the american people
because biden knows that he appears to
be a house plant to the american people
he can basically say whatever the hell
he wants and the media just treat it as
though it's a moderate thing so for
example
he's he he uttered one of the most
radical and yet weirdly
strangely just bizarre statements
yesterday
about the gop's voting policy so there's
this lie that is out there right now
that the gop
in georgia is passing a voting bill that
is extraordinarily radical it's trying
to curb voting rights this is stacey
abrams talking about voter suppression
okay the big lie
from the right in the last election was
that voter fraud and voter irregularity
decided the election
the big lie from the left for the last
several years is that voter suppression
was going to
decide elections and the media continued
to promulgate that lie that republicans
in asking for voter id so we know who
you are when you vote
that they are performing some sort of
voter suppression act that's nonsense
there's no statistical evidence to back
that they'll say things like you know
republicans when they don't want early
voting it's because they're trying to
suppress voting really because we have
this thing called election day
in fact if you really want to blow it
out i think that you should be able to
vote as early as possible in the 2037
elections
why not there will be a special election
in 2037 and you should be able to vote
right now for it in fact if you are not
in favor of voting
in advance for a party before candidates
have been chosen before you even know
what the race is
i think that you're trying a voter
suppression act now of course that's
absurd
on its face why should you vote six
months in advance of an election
why should vote four weeks in advance of
an election half of the news about an
election votes
breaks in the week before the election
but according to the democrats
if you do things like you say don't try
to bribe people in line that's what
georgia says georgia says you're not
allowed to give
gifts of money or food or drink to
people in line
for voting the way the media portrayed
that is republicans try to block people
from giving water to people in line that
is not what that bill is about
the bill is attempting to block people
from bribing people in line to vote
okay that is what it says in the text of
the law but the media created this lie
and the
lie was republicans are engaged in a
vast act of voter suppression all of
which led up to
the most bizarre line of joe biden's
very bizarre and disquieting press
conference
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about your safety and
security at home and also just knowing
what's going on at your house so as i've
mentioned
i have three kids they are absolutely
running me ragged and one of the things
about having three kids that i only have
one pair of eyes they tend to focus in
one direction only which means it's hard
to keep track of all three of my
children
the baby is now crawling around like a
like a crazy person and trying to hurt
herself
i've got a son who bounces off walls and
i've got a daughter who
is pretty with it but i will say that
i'd like to keep an eye on her as well
so three kids two eyes one direction
that means
what i actually need is ring devices on
my house so i can tell what the hell is
going on at home
so i can remain in control of my own
property you need this as well whether
it is just visitors stopping at your
front door
or is people dropping off packages
whether you just want notes going on
your property ring devices are the thing
i love having the ring video doorbell
i've actually added wearing security
cameras around my home as well no matter
your home
ring has everything you need to protect
it see and speak to whoever is at your
door from anywhere video doorbells keep
an eye on every corner of your house
with easy to install indoor and outdoor
cams protect your whole home with ring
alarm
it's a powerful affordable whole home
security system you can easily install
yourself right now
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kit at ringgit.com
it comes with the ring video doorbell 3
and chime pro it is the perfect way to
upgrade your front door and start
your ring experience head on over to
ring.com
that is ring dot com slash event okay so
again the democrats are pushing a lie
the lie
is that republicans are attempting an
act of voter suppression karl rove
points out in the wall street journal
today that this is not true
he says moves by republican legislators
to reform state election laws are
drawing incendiary accusations from
democrats former georgia gubernatorial
candidate stacey abrams denounced them
as jim crow in a suit and tie
vice president kamala harris declared
quote it's all voter suppression by any
other name
the democratic governors association
says these efforts are quote a direct
attack on our democracy
this is a lie in georgia republican
legislators are close to passing a bill
that expands the state's early voting
period by four days
what a clever gop suppression technique
provide voters with more opportunities
to cast ballots the legislation would
also require georgians to vote in their
home precinct or risk having their
ballot disqualified
it would forbid outside groups to send
duplicate applications for mail and
absence he ballots to voters who have
already applied for one
so you don't want two applications going
in for the same ballot both are sensible
protections
democrats are upset about the idea of a
voter id but if that's racist new jersey
virginia and california are suppression
hotbeds new jersey requires a driver's
license or the last four digits of a
social security number virginia requires
both a photo id and your social security
number and california requires id
at least to register ms abrams and her
allies also oppose efforts to toughen
signature verification for mail-in
ballots
but colorado has what's likely the
toughest such procedures in the country
which is important since it conducts
elections
primarily by mail last fall roughly one
of every 112 ballots 29 000 altogethers
was rejected because the signature
didn't match the one on file with
election officials
that was after voters were allowed to
cure problems by responding to a text
asking for a copy of their driver's
license or other photo id bearing their
signature
more than 11 000 did so are california's
democratic governor and legislator later
to be branded vote suppressors
again these voter id laws these voting
laws generally
these are not in any way racist they're
not about voter suppression they're
about shoring up voting procedures
but because democrats wish to federalize
election law and make it
easier than ever for the democratic
party to skew election results
with things like ballot harvesting
ballot harvesting is to my mind the most
dangerous
voting procedure that you could have in
a free country right now
having the party basically just deploy
activists door to door to go pick up
ballots from
just blue voters for example is a great
way of skewing elections it makes
elections not about who decides to vote
that day but about
how much money the democratic party can
spend on going door-to-door to actually
gather ballots and then have party
activists who cannot be trusted with the
ballots
drive those things over to the post
office for example or drive them to a
ballot box
it is ballot stuffing by any other name
in any case joe biden says that if
you wish to actually shore up voter id
that this is an act of racism not only
is it an act of racism
also he makes a reference that nobody
understands right here because this is
what joe biden does
again the combination of incoherence and
radicalism in this one statement
pure biden doesn't get more biden than
this here we go
the republican voters i know
find this despicable republican voters
the folks out in the outside this white
house
i'm not talking about the elected
officials
i'm talking about voters voters
and so i'm convinced that we'll be able
to stop this because it is the most
pernicious thing
this makes jim crow look like jim eagle
jim crow who the hell is jimmy eagle i
looked this up yesterday in in the
mistaken impression that perhaps i just
missed some sort of
cultural reference from 1832 because he
has a different frame of reference than
i do does joe biden considering that he
was actually
he was actually around when the pyramids
were built
so i thought maybe this was just some
reference i didn't get nope
that is not a thing there is no such
thing as jimmy eagle i feel bad for all
the people out there in america who are
named jim eagle
because today they're like what what's
he talking about now this makes jim crow
look like
jim woody woodpecker jim
jim dove jim jim
thrush jim eagle because the eagles are
patriotic and and
okay incoherence and radicalism all at
once that is the biden way
and and it didn't just stop there there
i mean there's the race baiting of
course
he he kept using terms like jim crow
with a level of comfort that even barack
obama
did not use jim crow joe biden who
again used to work with people who were
in favor of jim crow in the united
states senate as kamala harris pointed
out before she decided that he was
actually the greatest civil rights
fighter of her lifetime
joe biden said that he might get rid of
the filibuster so we're going to have
this adult
human this adult radical human talking
about getting rid of the filibuster and
the media are cheering it
by the way the real story here again is
not that biden is flipping on the
filibuster he spent years and years and
years defending the filibuster he was
the senate institutionalist he was the
guy who's going to stand up for the
deliberative body that is the senate and
it's magical procedures that allow for
conversation to take place
now of course he's like you know what
power's an instrument i'm in charge
sure i'd be interested in getting rid of
the filibuster the story isn't that
the story is that the media are openly
openly thirsting for it
they're sending thirst picks to joe
biden about the filibuster at this point
the media are just
they're begging for it every single day
they are going to senators
who are supposedly on the fence people
like kristin cinema of arizona and joe
manchin they ask them every single day
any update on getting rid of that
filibuster when are you guys going to
get rid of it please get rid of the
filibuster here was joe biden
saying you know after all maybe we
should get rid of the filibuster this
was the great defender of the filibuster
okay the democrats have come up with a
new narrative the new narrative is that
when republicans are
are in charge of the senate the
filibuster is a deeply necessary tool
for deliberative democracy and when
democrats are in charge of the senate
then the filibuster is a jim crow era
relic
that is really a holdover from america's
racist past here is joe biden
spewing out this garbage with regard to
the filibuster i believe
we should go back to a position in the
filibuster that existed
just when i came to united states senate
120 years ago
i strongly support moving in that
direction in addition to
having an open mind about dealing with
certain things that are are just
elemental to the functioning of our
democracy
like the right to vote like the basic
right to vote
we've amended the filibuster in the past
okay it's a jim crow ira relic okay he
was asked specifically if he thought
that it was a relic of the jim crow era
and the president said yes okay here is
joe biden in 2005 quote
at its core the filibuster is not about
stopping a nominee or a bill it's about
compromise and moderation it does not
mean i get in
i get my way it means you may have to
compromise that is what it is about
about engendering compromise and
moderation here's barack obama
circa 2005 talking about how important
the filibuster is
the american people want less
partisanship in this town but everyone
in this chamber knows
that if the majority chooses to end the
filibuster
if they choose to change the rules and
put an end to democratic debate
then the fighting and the bitterness and
the gridlock will only get worse
i understand that republicans are
getting a lot of pressure to do this
from factions outside the chamber
but we need to rise above the ends
justify the means mentality because
we're here to answer to the people
all of the people not just the ones that
are wearing our particular party label
uh except for the fact that this is the
way that the democrats run things the
way democrats run things is
we love the procedures so long as the
procedures protect us
but the minute that we are in charge
those procedures go directly out the
window then they wonder why politics has
become a cynical exercise in partisan
power grabbing because you guys are
doing this
chuck schumer the other day he cited
statistics about how the filibuster has
been used to obstruct legislation so
many times
he was citing statistics from when the
democrats were using the filibuster to
obstruct legislation it was unbelievable
okay this is chuck schumer yesterday
talking about how
we when we filibuster it's good when
they filibuster it's bad
he was asked about the filibuster he's
basically like yeah the filibuster is a
terrible thing because now we're in
charge
the big difference is that we were
always willing to negotiate in a
bipartisan way
mitch mcconnell isn't the bills he puts
on the floor even when he calls them
bipartisan aren't
like the first care spill like
the policing bill there's no discussion
no discussion
we are sitting down i am encouraging my
colleagues to sit down with republicans
and move forward
there's a big difference in how we're
conducting things in the way they're
conducting he's just an effing liar the
man's just an effing liar
he is a liar that is a lie okay when
democrats pushed legislation like
obamacare they didn't have a single
republican vote
when democrats have the democrats just
passed a giant spending bill with no
republican support in the senate
none okay what in the hell is he talking
about
they filibustered tim scott's police
reform bill chuck schumer participated
in that filibuster again this is all
cynical it's also
there's no principle here joe biden is
not a principled man joe biden is a
power grabbing man
he's a power grabbing c he is a
paragraphing man in decline
okay and his party is perfectly willing
to go along with this they're excited
about it the the same media the same
democrats who decried donald trump's
behavior between the election and
january 6th
and said that he was cynically using his
power in order to manipulate elections
these are the same exact people who are
out there right now saying that they
have the ability to actively overturn
elections nancy pelosi said yesterday
that she has the singular ability to bar
people from entering congress
no matter how they got into congress
okay this is this is authoritarian talk
from the speaker of the house
now if i wanted to be unfair i wouldn't
have seeded the dem the republican from
iowa
because that was my right on the opening
day i would have just said
they're not seated and that would be my
right as speaker to do
unbelievable unbelievable she says that
as speaker of the house she has the
ability to deny seating somebody who's
legit elected from a particular district
she's talking about an iowa district
right now that is separated by about six
votes
okay and she says she doesn't want to
seat the republican anymore
okay but so power is just a tool for
these people there's no
principled institutional loyalty here it
is all about the use of power and you
wonder why their reactionaries on the
right we're like you know what screw the
all the systems we're done with the
systems we're just gonna do whatever the
hell we want if we ever get power again
we're just gonna junk these systems and
do whatever the hell we want because you
guys don't care about the institutions
you wonder why that sentiment is rising
if you care about america's institutions
if you wish those institutions to remain
so we can actually have discussions
about policy
come to some sort of broad-ranging
agreement for the 330 people
330 million people who live in america
and may disagree about fundamental
policy
policies and politics if you hope those
institutions hold because the
institutions are kind of important
the left is wrecking those institutions
and the wrecking ball is an adult old
man
who is not with us the the democratic
party is being run
by a san francisco leftist worth
tens of millions of dollars completely
out of touch with the american people
who is 183 years old and a president of
the united states who can't string
together a sentence
and the media are cheering it because
you know who's in charge people keep
asking us who's in charge
really who's in charge over there at the
white house i'll tell you who's in
charge the media are in charge
the establishment media are in charge
they are driving the agenda they're
willing to cover for the agenda what
they are not willing to cover for is
what gets covered
the media are the ones in charge because
politicians respond to incentive
structures and you know what creates the
incentive structures these days
it is not the american people
predominantly it is the media who create
the narratives that shift how the
american people think
the establishment media are the biggest
obstacles
to a to a defense of your individual
rights
in america today not the courts not the
government
the incentive structure being set up by
an establishment media that continues
to force its dominance on the american
people day after day and when they don't
dominate they seek to just destroy
all methods of informational
dissemination you wonder why i think
that what we do here at daily wire is
kind of important
because these folks wish us not to do it
that is why
okay in a second we'll get to joe biden
on the border because there are serious
questions to be asked
about joe biden's behavior on the border
and his administration's policies on the
board he's not going to answer any of
them however we'll get to that in just
one second first
let us talk about getting a good night's
sleep so as i've mentioned
my babies have been keeping me up
they've just been keeping me up
really late uh my daughter is teething
she's got the molars in that means i'm
not getting as much sleep as i'd like it
means that when i do get in bed i need
all of this i need all of my sleep
products to just be top quality and that
is why i love
my pillow my pillow products they don't
go flat you can wash and dry them as
many times as you want they maintain
their shape best of all they're made
right here in the united states if you
don't have a my pillow or know somebody
who doesn't
now is the time to get one because for a
limited time my pillow is offering their
premium my pillows for their lowest
price ever
you can get a queen size premium my
pillow regularly 69.98 for just 29.
98 that is 40 bucks in savings kings are
only five bucks more
folks now is the time to buy not only
are you getting the lowest price ever
but
they are the best gifts ever they are
29.98 for a queen size premium at my
pillow and you buy now they'll extend
the 60-day money back guarantee go to
mypillow.com click on that radio
listener square there you'll find not
only this amazing offer but also deep
discounts on all my pillow products
including
the giza dream bed sheets the my pillow
mattress topper and my pillow towel sets
or call 800
651 1148 use promo code daily wire
to get started alrighty in just one
second when he gets to joe biden on the
border
incredible how the media just again
they're covering for him
in the same way that the media covered
for jfk stooping the interns in the
white house swimming pool
that is how they are covering for his
crappy radical policies they're covering
for the fact that he is not with us
it's amazing first let me remind you
this sunday
we do have a ben shapiro sunday special
it is with ion hercieli
perhaps the bravest woman in
international politics obviously
subjected to enormous hatred
both originally in the netherlands and
now in the united states for not
moving along with the left-wing
shibboleth that you normally hear
uh ayan is uh not only a person with
great personal bravery but great insight
into the radical left and the identity
politics left that seems to be
predominating at this time check out the
sunday special this week it's really
really good
also it is that glorious time of the
week when i give a shout out to a daily
wire member today
it is alison thomas on instagram who
understands the right stance when it
comes to the insane
cancel mob in the picture an adorable
baby is sitting in a chair with the
world's most elite beverage vessel while
holding a book
the constitution the declaration of
independence also in the chair numerous
other books including the bible
dr sue shakespeare mark twain various
disney titles and gone with the win the
caption reads
come and burn them hashtag leftist ears
tumblr hashtag bandbox
readers are leaders well done that's
some good parenting right there thank
you for the picture and for being
a daily wire member if you haven't heard
by now but honestly if you listen to me
as much as you should you would have
heard of course
candace owens has a brand new talk show
with us exclusively at dailywire.com
the full show is available to daily wire
members only
the second episode of candace airs today
it's gonna have all sorts of good stuff
in it frankly i can't wait to watch it
myself so
if you need some candace owens in your
life look no further head on over to
dailywire.com
subscribe today plus quick note our team
here at dailywire has an opening
you want to work here now's your chance
we need a data analyst if data is your
thing we are looking for you
candidate skills and background should
include two or more years of product and
data analytics experience in the
industries of streaming media platforms
subscription products or ecommerce
proficiency in analytics software like
mixpanel and snowflake
strong visual and verbal communication
skills for presenting data clearly
this is a national based role qualified
candidates can apply through
dailywire.com
careers also a quick reminder since we
are approaching
the weekend fast again now is a great
time to subscribe head on over to
dailywire.com
subscribe and subscribe it right now we
have all sorts of brand new stuff coming
online
all sorts of awesome new stuff that is
already online candidacy show are all
access i know the canvas didn't all
access this week
we have tons of fun stuff going on
become part of the club head on over to
dailywire.com
subscribe and become a member you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
consumer podcast and radio show in the
nation
[Music]
all righty so joe biden again if you're
wondering who exactly is in control the
answer is the establishment media that
has set up all the incentive structures
here
and if you want to see that in action
yesterday joe biden was asked about this
crisis at the border the crisis at the
border is
of his own making it is it is a crisis
that has been driven by
joe biden's warm embrace of illegal
immigration
he encouraged an actual surge in the
middle of the primaries last year
joe biden has said openly that he was
not going to deport anyone
when he got into office and people
rushed the border that is the most
predictable thing in the entire world
and the media cheered him on throughout
that process well yesterday
he was asked some questions about the
border and his answers
on to these questions are not only
incoherent
they were full of untruths that could
have been fact-checked in real time
where was daniel dale where were all the
fact checkers weird he made an entire
career out of fact-checking everything
trump said taking everything extremely
literally
trying to parse every single statement
joe biden just says things that are
overtly untrue and daniel
dale is nowhere to be found they put him
in witness protection over at cnn
i mean not only does joe biden lie here
he also just acts
weird okay so for example he was asked
about
the treatment of children in these
migrant facilities
you know kids in cages he was asked by
cecilia vega who good for her actually
asked
a question about this the abc news chief
white house correspondent
it does it does put me in a weird
position when i now have to
praise journalists for doing like the
most basic element of their job
asking about the news but she did she
asked biden about the news and biden
started to chuckle
okay just watch the clip what is your
reaction to these images that have come
out from that particular facility
is what's happening inside acceptable to
you
and when is this going to be fixed is
that's a serious question right
is it acceptable to me come on that's
why
we're going to be moving a thousand of
those kids out quickly
is it acceptable yes that was the
question is it acceptable to you
and do you think that if donald trump
it's not acceptable it wouldn't matter
but he's joe biden so he gets away with
that kind of treatment of the press no
problem
whatsoever and then his policies are
absolutely self-conflicting they make no
sense at all
so biden first of all he's asked when
are you gonna be transparent and let the
media in there he's like i don't know
and be like okay amazing here we go
we haven't seen the facilities in which
children are packed together to really
give the american people a chance to see
that will you commit to transparency on
this
i will commit to transparency and as
soon as i am in a position to be able to
implement
what we're doing right now and one of
the reasons i haven't gone down
i've all my my chief folks have gone
down
is i don't want to become the issue i
don't want to be
you know bringing all the secret service
and everybody
with me to get in the way so this is
being set up
and you'll have full access to
everything
once we get this thing moving just to be
clear how soon will that be mr president
i don't know
okay all right cause i'm not going down
there because i don't want to bring
attention sure i'm sure that that i'm
i'm sure that's why it's not because
you don't want pictures of you
juxtaposed with kids in cages
it's not because of that it's just you
don't want to be a distraction joe biden
oh weird because that's never seemed to
stop you before so that's strange
but don't worry you guys will get in
when none
who's that gym man and your children's
game name drum blood pressure
and the media well okay all right good
enough for me okay then there's the
actual
failures and contradictions so he says
you know
i should be flattered that people are
coming i should be flattered that
illegal immigrants are arriving in
wave numbers so he says simultaneously
two things one i'm going to deport
people
but i'm not going to deport people and
two it's not my fault they're coming but
if they are coming it's because i'm
great it's like
what in the world and the meter like
morons okay here are members of the
media and joe biden here's your misha
alcindor from pbs newshour by the way
your taxpayer
dollars pay for this kind of journalism
i guess i should be flattered
people are coming because i'm the nice
guy that's the reason why it's happening
that i'm a decent man or whoever's
phrased that you know that's why they're
coming because no biden's a good guy
truth of the matter is nothing has
changed yes what changed is you
what changed is you why should you be
flattered that we're having an
inundation at our border
you know there are other americans in
america besides joe biden the fact that
he sees everything through the prism of
they think i'm such a nice guy
every president defines himself in a
particular way joe biden defines himself
as the nice guy who quote unquote gets
things done
the problem is the things he's getting
done are crappy and the nice guy routine
is bringing
literally tens of thousands if not
millions of people to the border over
the course of this year
okay then joe biden says he said a bunch
of untrue things here he said in the
middle of this immigration talk
in his presser yesterday he said for
example that the
he said the trump administration was
simply sending people back to the desert
to die
that was an overt lie that is just
untrue did anybody fact-check him was it
like can you name a person who has died
in the desert because they were sent
back to the desert that's not how it
works when people arrive at the border
they're immediately handed over to
mexican authorities or
they're shipped back to country of
origin
it's not as though at the border like
you know what you came here back to the
desert with you
no water bottles enjoy that's not how it
works
joe biden knows that but he's a damned
liar so here he was yesterday saying
and then he and then he says you know
what if kids have family elsewhere we
should deport them okay this is a
complete reversal
from his own policy which is that if
kids show up here we're not going to
deport them his dhs secretary said that
this week
do you want to see these unaccompanied
minors
staying in this ch this country or
should they be deported eventually
well the judgment has to be made whether
or not in this young man's case he has a
mom at home
there's an overwhelming reason why he'd
be putting a plane and flown back to his
mom oh you mean the trump administration
cruel evil policy
that that policy that's exactly the
policy is currently talking about
maybe the media didn't fact-check him he
said on true things throughout but again
he's a nice elderly gentleman how dare
you
point any of this out and th this is
really about the
stenographer pool this is about the
stenographer pool that lives in that
white house press room
and all of the people on cnn and msnbc
who just
engage in the human centipede peter
ducey at fox news the only journalist
who ever asks any tough questions
apparently
in that white house press room he talked
yesterday about the fact that he was not
called on
again president doesn't have to call on
anybody but the fact that that biden
was standing there and going down a list
of approved reporters demonstrates
exactly what they think
of the press pool here with peter ducey
i mentioned last night uh on special
report that i had a binder full of
questions i think some people were
kidding i was not kidding we
had a lot and most of this stuff did not
get to but the last one that i can think
of like this would have been in
wilmington
they had an aid off to the side with the
list
of reporters to call on today it was
biden with
the list and once they got through about
an hour and 20 minutes
uh he was done i'm not sure if that was
the end of the list
if we were on it he did not make it down
that far
okay he did not make it down that far
yeah of course he didn't
he just started randomly wobbling off
into into the ether he had no idea what
he was doing he had no idea what the
hell he was talking about
and there were many questions that he
didn't get to you know he didn't answer
a single question about coveted
yesterday not one
his 62 minute press conference didn't
answer a single question about covid
remember the most important issue of our
lifetimes remember
an issue so important that we not only
have to blow out two trillion dollars in
spending that we just did this month we
need to blow out another three trillion
dollars in spending and at no point was
he asked about covet by her intrepid
press
at no point was he asked about for
example hunter biden because it turns
out that there's a new breaking scandal
with hunter biden at no point was he
asked about that
you think trump would have been asked
about similar issues of course he would
have
but the agenda is all that matters to
the press i'm not
disappointed in biting because i didn't
have any expectations of biden i didn't
think
he was going to be some sort of moderate
institutionalist who was going to uphold
the great institutions of american
democracy in pursuit of some sort of
bipartisan compromise i never thought he
was going to be that
hey but that's that's not what the media
said for years if you pointed out that
joe biden was not a moderate and that he
didn't care about the institutions
you were told that you were out of your
mind he wasn't some crazy radical like
bernie
he was going to bring america back
together
i'm not surprised when when politicians
lie to me
i'm not even surprised when the media
lie to me i'm just surprised at this
point that anybody buys it anymore
i think fewer and fewer people are going
to buy it over time
alrighty well once in a while we check
in with our friends over at birch gold
over the past couple of days i had a
chance to talk with philip patrick he's
a precious metal specialist over at
birch gold he had some
pretty interesting insight into what
exactly the biden administration is
doing and how that could impact
your finances and of course why it may
be worthwhile diversifying into precious
metals
here's something we recorded a little
bit earlier this week joining us on the
line is
philip patrick he's a precious metals
specialist with our friends over
at birch gold and we thought now would
be an excellent time to talk about why
investing
in precious metals might just be a good
idea philip thanks so much for joining
the program
thanks for having us so let's talk for a
second about the
value of the united states dollar so the
biden administration is clearly blowing
out the spending they just dropped two
trillion dollars
on a brand new stimulus package which is
unnecessary given the fact that we are
now in the waiting days of the pandemic
and now
at the federal reserve's meeting last
week federal chair jerome
powell indicated he expects interest
rates to remain at near zero through
2023 which is kind of a wild idea what's
your take on that look
it's certainly a wild idea and i think
they have to keep interest rates
low for a couple of reasons really the
first is the reason they drop them in
the first place which is to encourage
spending
right low interest rates encourage
people to take money out of savings and
essentially invest it right the stock
market real estate bond market it fuels
activity and essentially keeps this
thing propped up
um the second side of it is obviously
debt right debt is growing significantly
we're approaching 30 trillion dollars
which is just about manageable for the
government because interest rates are so
low
um if they start to raise rates the
average rate on our debt
federally for the last 30 years has been
about five percent
the interest payments on our debt start
to become untenable
um in relation to tax revenue so
the statement makes sense i think they
have to okay but because they have to
this means that we probably should
expect some inflation to kick in in the
if not near future than in the medium
future so if higher rates of inflation
are coming
then um diversification seems like it
might be a good idea
yeah look you hit the nail on the head
low interest rates in isolation are not
necessarily an issue you couple that
with rising inflation which to some
degree is unavoidable
that's when it starts to become
problematic you're absolutely spot on
so if you were looking at diversifying
why not put your money in say stocks for
example
look stocks historically have been a
very good hedge
against inflation they've outperformed
it longer term but that doesn't mean
that there are not
issues in the market short to medium
term right you look at the stock market
from a timing standpoint
it's cyclical right the stock market
will typically correct in seven to ten
year cycles we're now
two and a half years into the longest
bull run in
recorded history outside of that some of
the numbers there look concerning
price-to-earning ratios are a level
today that they've never been at in
history
without us suffering a fairly sizable
correction so
short to medium term it seems a little
bit frightening and how about bonds a
lot of people have been talking about
bonds as a safe haven but
in a time when it appears that the bond
yields are going up there's less demand
for bonds why do you think that the
demand for bonds seems to be going down
i think it ties into interest rates
right you buy a secure bond today and i
think they are
u.s government treasuries a five-year
treasury note today is paying less than
one percent
annually uh according to the government
inflation rates are higher than that
today so you know you buy a government
treasury today you lose
money on the back of inflation you lose
buying power
my issue is the inflation numbers put
out are a little bit misleading they
don't include
food or energy anymore you start to
factor that in inflation is higher than
published today
sitting in bonds becomes problematic in
this sort of climate
so if you were going to invest in
precious metals what would you suggest
to folks as as possible ways to invest
in precious metals to dip a tone or or
maybe a little bit more
look it depends on you know the
individual's comfort level of course
but i think they're a very suitable tool
for this sort of climate if you look at
our
issues potentially on the horizon we
have stock market correction we have
inflation we have currency devaluation
these sort of issues
actually drive safe havens like gold and
silver up
right when stocks crash people can flood
to gold and silver 2008 was a great
example they
doubled in value the technical
definition of inflation is the rising
cost of
commodities and services over time
intrinsically gold and silver are
commodities by definition they keep pace
so
they're very conducive for climates like
this specifically
all righty well that is philip patrick
from birch gold he of course a precious
metals
specialist obviously if you are looking
to get involved in precious metals i
trust the folks over at birch gold and
for good reason
because they will give you all the
straight answers about what kind of
investment strategy you ought to pursue
the reality of the situation is that we
are now watching an administration that
is blowing out the dollar it's only a
matter of time before inflation does in
fact
kick in you've seen this in the demand
for gold you've seen this in demand for
other assets that are not the us dollar
phillip patrick thanks so much for your
time really appreciate your insight
thank you ben thanks for having us that
is phillip patrick a precious metal
specialist over at birch gold group
as you know the people over at birch
gold are the people i trust with my own
precious metals investing text bends
47 47 47 for your free information kit
on precious metals iras or to speak
with a birch gold representative today
again that's my name text at bend 47
47 47 to get started with my friends
over at birch gold
already meanwhile i got to tell you
about a couple of the topics that they
didn't actually get to
okay so a few topics they didn't get to
not a single question was asked
in this press conference about joe
biden's coveted policy
not one which is kind of amazing
remember it's the most important issue
ever
we shut down the entire economy of the
united states for a year
remember we're spending more money than
has ever been spent in the history of
humanity
that is not an exaggeration we are now
spending more money than any government
has ever spent ever ever can we are
doing so on the back of a pandemic that
is already on the wane
he was not asked a single question about
that and he was not asked a single
question about for example
school reopenings he read some talking
points about school reopenings where he
talked about maybe we'll have to reopen
some schools and that'll be great
by the way if you actually look at a
chart of the states that have reopened
their schools versus the states that
have not
it is a complete blue red divide the
vast majority of blue states have kept
kids out of school the vast majority of
red states have not
and then you're going to tell me it's
all about the science okay biden's own
people right now
are not committing to reopening schools
in the fall here is biden's education
secretary
yesterday saying that they're not sure
if the schools are going to reopen in
the fall
how is he not asked about this you know
it's premature to tell one thing that i
know as a
former commissioner of education covet
19 numbers will dictate how we move
to reopen schools so it's not just about
what's happening in the schools it's
about what's happening in the community
if as members of our community we can
follow those mitigation strategies
to make sure that our schools are safe
places for our students and for our
staff
we should have students in school uh
next year we should have them in school
in the spring
remember when this was the party of
science yeah not the party of science so
much yes the school should be open now
they should have been open
months ago my kids have been in school
the entire year it is a travesty
particularly targeting minority students
that the schools have not been open
and you still have members of this it's
too soon to tell whether we're going to
open in the fall
this is nuts meanwhile speaking of the
party of science remember
the school reopening policy has been
driven almost entirely at this point by
the teachers unions
i was told that to deny the unique
knowledge and power of the cdc
and the american federal government to
do that was to engage in a sort of
anti-scientific propagandizing
or if you oppose anthony fauci anywhere
in here it's because you opposed the
science
if you suggested for example that
perhaps
the virus that cova 19 sprang
from a lab leak in china as senator tom
cotton suggested you were ripped up and
down because hey how dare you that's
fomenting xenophobia
now it turns out the former cdc chair
robert redfield
he has now come out and he says oh yeah
by the way it probably leads from a lab
in china
he just said that today okay but if
you're talking about people who do not
give a damn about science they only care
about the agenda
there's an amazing story from u.s news
and world report lauren camera writing
quote the president of the country's
most politically powerful teachers union
called into question the center for
disease control and prevention's
decision last week to revise from six
feet to three feet
its social distancing guideline in
schools arguing the science backing the
decision doesn't take into account
the unique challenges most urban school
districts face okay so the cdc came out
in the last couple of weeks
and they announced that kids don't need
to be six feet apart in schools they
probably only need to be three feet
apart in schools by the way the six feet
standard came from absolutely nowhere if
you are somebody who is like a deep
believer in six feet six feet six feet
there was like no scientific basis to
six feet if somebody sneezes
it goes like 15 feet if you're not
sneezing it doesn't go six feet it goes
like
two feet okay but the media kept from
if you don't stay six feet away from
that guy next to you it's because you're
in the schools man we got to keep these
kids at least six feet apart then the
cdc comes along and
they're like oh yeah by the way totally
wrong about that we could have
have the size of the school classrooms
and been fine kids can be three feet
apart
and the teachers unions because they're
running at the agenda and they don't
want to go back to school ever
they just want to get paid for staying
home and zooming in they say
they're not going to listen to the cdc
are we seeing headlines today about how
the teachers unions are anti-science
about how the scientific agenda is being
thwarted by the teachers unions oh yeah
i didn't think so the american
federation of teachers president randy
weingarten one of the worst people in
america
wrote tuesday in a letter to cdc
director rochelle wolensky and education
secretary miguel cardona quote
although i was very worried about the
implications of the shift i reviewed
judgment until we could review the new
studies that we
that were presented we have done that
this weekend we appreciate that the body
of knowledge regarding the impact of
covet 19 in school environments is
expanding
but we're not convinced the evidence
supports changing physical distancing
requirements at this time
our concern is that the cited studies do
not identify the baseline mitigation
strategies
needed to support three feet of physical
distancing moreover they were not
conducted in our nation's
highest density and least resourced
schools which have poor ventilation
crowding and other structural challenges
okay my favorite part of that is when
randy
weingarten is like we haven't tried this
in the school so we don't know if it
works
right because the schools are closed the
question is under what circumstances
you're going to reopen the schools
you want to talk about anti-scientific
it's like okay so here's our theory we
tried this theory it didn't work so our
new theory
is that we don't need to do that they're
like well you haven't tested that theory
so probably we'll go back to the first
theory what in the world are you talking
about that's not how science works
once you've debunked a hypothesis you
don't go back to that hypothesis five
seconds later
based on the fact you haven't tried
another hypothesis it's ridiculous
by the way schools have been open all
over the world they've been open in asia
they've been open in israel they've been
open
particularly for elementary students
they've been opened in europe they've
been opened in vast swaths of the united
states but don't worry the teachers
unions are all about the signs they're
all about the science joe biden was not
asked a single question
about any of that he's not no questions
about that
meanwhile other things he was not asked
questions about it's an
unbelievable story from politico okay
reported by tara palmeri and ben
schreckenger
okay in politico on october 23rd 2018
president joe biden son hunter
and daughter-in-law hallie were involved
in a bizarre incident in which halle
took hunter's gun
and threw it in a trash can behind a
grocery store only to return later to
find it gone
delaware police began investigating
concern that the trash can was across
from a high school
and that the missing gun could be used
in a crime according to law enforcement
officials and a copy of the police
report obtained by politico
but a curious thing happened at the time
secret service agents approached the
owner of the store where hunter a
derelict
bought the gun and asked to take the
paperwork involving the sale according
to two people
one of whom has firsthand knowledge of
the episode and the other was briefed by
a secret service agent after the fact
the gun store owner refused to supply
the paperwork suspecting correctly that
the secret service officers wanted to
hide hunter's ownership of the missing
gun in case it were to be involved in a
crime the two people said
the owner ron palmieri later turned over
the papers to the bureau of alcohol
tobacco firearms and explosives which
oversees federal gun laws
the secret service says it has no record
of its agents investigating the incident
joe biden who's not under protection at
the time said through a spokesperson he
has no knowledge of any secret service
involvement
days later the gun was returned by an
older man who regularly rummages through
the grocery store's trash to collect
recyclables according to people familiar
with the situation
the incident did not result in charges
or arrests okay so
just to get this straight what happened
apparently
is that hunter he was dating his
brother's widow i think is the story
here
and they she for some odd reason
took his gun and threw it in the garbage
bin
behind a store which was across from a
high school
and the secret service then went and
tried to clean it up and there will be
no charges around resulting these are
the same people who are like
we need strict gun laws guys gun laws we
need them we need strict gun laws so
that people who mistreat mishandle
weapons get prosecuted unless her name
is hunter biden apparently
the gun store incident occurred during a
period after hunter biden's
administrative discharge from the naval
reserves for his positive
cocaine test and a subsequent divorce
from his first wife kathleen at the time
of the gun incident hunter was in a
romantic relationship with hallie the
widow of his late brother beau
apparently he illegally obtained aegon
he got it
he bought the gun october 12th 2018. he
responded no
to a question on the transaction record
that asked are you an unlawful user of
or addicted to
marijuana or any depressant stimulant
narcotics rug or any other controlled
substance five years earlier he had been
discharged from the navy reserve after
testing positive for coke he and family
members have spoken about his history of
drug use
lying on the form of a felony though
prosecutions are extremely rare so
it sounds like he bought the gun
illegally that's what it sounds like
because there's fairly good
contemporaneous evidence that hunter was
not off the sauce
and then he was dating his brother's
widow
and apparently the incident began when
hallie searched hunter's pickup which
was parked at her home in wilmington
because of unspecified suspicions she
had
according to a delaware state police
report inside the truck she found a 38
revolver
hallie took the gun to jansen's market a
nearby high-end grocery store where the
bidens are long-time regular customers
there she tossed the gun wrapped in a
black shopping bag into a trash bin
outside of the store which by the way is
not the way that you get rid of guns
just note to the wise if you have a
functional weapon you know what you
don't do to get rid of it just toss it
in the garbage can you morons
later that day hallie informed hunter of
what she had done instructed her to
retrieve the gun according to the police
report
when halley returned she found the gun
was missing and reported the issue to
the store
police received calls from the store's
general manager paula jansen and from
another person according to the report
the missing gun caused heightened
concern according to the police report
because the grocery sits across from the
alex dupont high school
arriving on the scene delaware state's
retrieved security camera footage from
the store interviewed jansen the store
manager quote we complied with the
police gave them whatever security
footage we could jansen told politico
the fbi also responded at the time the
fbi was already monitoring hunter as
part of an investigation that remains
ongoing and currently focuses on his
taxes
no comment from the fbi in addition to
questioning hallie police called hunter
to the scene he was questioned outside
the store's loading dock area and
explained he used the gun for target
practice
at one point two of jansen's employees
described by the police report as
mexican males
walked past the loading dock area and
hunter told a police officer the store
had some suspicious people working for
it
asked if he was referring to those two
staffers hunter responded yeah probably
illegal
according to the report because he's a
racist also
he's a drug addled gun-toting racist who
illegally obtained his weapon
no problems here guys everything is
totally fine
this story has all the things all of
them two mexican workers walk
past he's like oh those are probably
illegal based on what the fact that
they're mexican extraction
and based on the fact that you're
apparently a criminal
when a police officer asked hunter
whether the gun had been used in a crime
the officer reported hunter quote became
very agitated with me and asked if i was
intentionally trying to make him mad
when the officer asked hunter whether he
had been doing drugs or drinking heavily
he said listen it isn't like that i
think she believes i was going to kill
myself
according to the report an officer asked
hunter whether he had called his dad
hunter said i've caught i've never
called my dad for anything according to
the police report which we know is a lie
after being questioned hunter retrieved
the gun for the case for the gun which
included the gun serial number from
halley's house returned to the grocery
store and handed it over to the cops
when police questioned hunter and halley
two secret service agents arrived
they went to the store where hunter
purchased the gun the agents showed
their badges and id cards
to palmieri the store's owner and asked
to take possession of the firearms
transaction record hunter had filled out
she said no she the the
palmieri said no i'm not going to do
that
the secret service left without the the
records and palmieri
hands it over the transaction record to
the atf
acf spokesperson referred questions to
the delaware states jason hatchell
spokesperson for delaware state police
said any freedom of information
uh any questions about the incident
would have to be filed through a foia
request
the delaware state police already
rejected politico's voya request for
records related to the incident last
november
it's it's amazing okay there's been no
major media coverage of this
because that's what the establishment
media will never cover is the fact that
hunter biden is a derelict and his dad
knew about it for years and
apparently facilitated their election in
a wide variety of cases including
hunter rushing about the globe picking
up bags of cash
in different places a white house
spokesperson said biden was not aware of
any secret
service involvement in the episode just
change the number just change the name
biden to trump and imagine the size of
the scandal but don't worry
biden is a good guy he's a nice guy so
we don't cover what happened with hunter
by the way speaking of hypocrisy
authoritarianism by the way relies on
hypocrisy
the cuomo family also apparently has
engaged in an enormous amount of
hypocrisy
it turns out according to the new york
times governor andrew cuomo's
administration arranged special access
to government-run coronavirus testing
for members of his family
and other influential people as the
pandemic descended on new york last year
the move to make testing of people
closely tied to cuomo a priority was
carried out by high-ranking state health
officials
according to one of the people it
happened in march 2020 testing was still
not widely available
but andrew made sure that his family
members had it just like
our brand new deputy secretary of health
and human services dr
rachel levine ensured that dr levine's
mom was not in a nursing home when all
the covered positive patients were being
shipped back into the nursing homes
weird how this seems to keep it
happening with democrats how the rules
don't apply to them
the gun control left has no worries
about hunter biden
a a drug addicted derelict
leaving his gun out and then having it
thrown in a garbage can behind a high
school
and lying apparently on his forms about
obtaining the gun in the first place
that's totally fine but you law-abiding
citizen you need to lose your gun you
can't get a test
in new york in march 2020 but you know
who can if your last name is cuomo
you can get a test and then you can go
on national tv and you can hang out with
your bro
and talk about the size of your nostrils
and did mom love you best
yes we need to give more more power and
control to these folks more power and
control top down they're going to fix
everything and they care about you
they don't care about their own they
care about you they're just caring and
nice
and wonderful amazing amazing stuff
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content first
you cannot forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show
drew's show is every friday he's got an
exciting evening
planned for you so head on over to
dailywire.com this evening at 7 00 pm
eastern
tune in also make sure that you check
out our sunday special here's a little
bit of the trailer
i don't think that radical islamic
doctrine or its agenda
is capable of defeating western society
it's just
militarily economically not
capable of doing that but if the west
implodes
that's going to come from the inside
[Music]
if you like that trailer you're going to
love the actual sunday special it was
fantastic we talked about
the the rise of radical islam we talked
about the coincidence between radical
islam and the woke left what they have
in common there's a lot there you're
gonna want to give it a listen go check
it out this weekend on the sunday
special
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin